[Music]
on this tuesday night canada's dangerous
new wave of variant cases
it really felt like a groundhog day
the surge in cases and hospitalizations
and warnings the pandemic is entering a
new phase
big blow to business no one saw it
coming
the shock and consequences of bc's
circuit breaker lockdown
a new report card exposing tragic
shortcomings in canada's long-term care
homes
we have a grossly underfunded system and
virtual
gurus there's just no opportunities for
me the canadian tech startup helping
women
find work
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is news tonight about vaccines and
variants the highly transmissible
variants of covet 19 are on the rise in
parts of this country
and public health experts warn this
third wave is unlike
the first two case counts are climbing
faster
younger people are getting sicker
hospital icus are filling up
today prime minister justin trudeau said
anyone thinking of gathering for easter
or
passover should know the situation is
now more dangerous
than it's ever been i know i've said the
same thing before every major holiday
over the past year
but this time what's different is that
even if the end of the pandemic is in
sight the variants
mean the situation is even more serious
over the last week the number of new
variant cases in canada jumped 64
percent
more than 9 000 have now been confirmed
and canada's public health agency says
that's just
the tip of the iceberg thousands of
other tests that have shown red flags
for the variants are waiting to be
confirmed
in the last week the number of coveted
patients in intensive care units rose
14 percent the need for vaccines is
acute the federal government promised
today more are
on the way and now fit now says to get
every canadian at least one dose well
before the end of september
more on that in just a moment but we
begin with the variance they are winning
the race against vaccines right now
especially in bc and ontario
where scientists say the situation is
completely
out of control eric sorenson begins our
coverage
tonight what could be more encouraging
in a coveted hot spot like toronto then
better weather
and a loosening of restrictions for
activities like outdoor dining
but don't be misled nearby inside some
toronto and area hospitals a much more
discouraging scene
hospital beds and intensive care units
are filling up again
ontario's science advisory panel
suggests covid variants
now account for 67 percent of all covid
cases in the province
and they seem to be hitting younger
people the percentage of patients under
age 60 in icu beds
has risen 50 percent since december so
they're they're younger
they're younger and they're sicker this
emergency room doctor says it's as bad
as it was in january
yesterday i had an emergency shift and
it really felt
like i felt at the peak of wave 2. here
are the coveted curves for ontario since
december for infections for
hospitalizations and for icu cases
the second wave happened in january but
now you can clearly see a third wave has
begun in march
note there was a provincial lockdown
just after christmas
as of march 28 there were just as many
infections as there were on december
26th
and for icu cases and for
hospitalizations the numbers are even
higher now than they were then
and these numbers will continue to rise
ontario is preparing two field hospitals
this one in toronto and another in
hamilton to increase hospital capacity
but as demand for icu beds is sure to
increase
so are demands for another lockdown
right now what we're seeing in the gta
they need to put on the emergency brake
and they need to close schools
closing schools would be a very big
change of course for ontario
premier doug ford says he's prepared to
act but for now is only warning against
travel and gatherings over the easter
weekend
i'm asking you don't make plans for
easter that's what i can i can tell you
i won't hesitate to
you know lock things down if we have to
i did it before i'll do it again
another hopeful sign vaccinations but
it's clear they won't protect us soon
enough to avert what's happening now
it's not going to stop the third wave it
may blunt
the impact of the third wave and maybe
shorten its duration somewhat
but we're going to have some suffering
in the next few weeks or months
a tough time ahead for ontario and it's
not the only province
i'm robin gill in whistler b.c the
resort has been shut down because those
variants are taking hold in this
community
it's a major setback and it feels very
much
like march 2020 all over again
this is what skiers look forward to a
bluebird day
but the lifts aren't moving the passes
now a waste
we thought it's safe best place to be is
outside
these spring breakers can't catch a
break the ski hill was closed last year
at the same time this is what happened
last year too with
with these kids it was like as soon as
their spring break started
was the same day that the mountain
closed down last year the province has
shut whistler blackcomb and workers
don't know what's happening next
it's an abrupt end to the season for
sure which
yeah no one saw it coming this is the
height of the spring ski season
and it's a big economic bite is that
taking a sledgehammer to your business
this year has dramatically impacted us
we're a
tourism community and that's what keeps
this place going
and in a coveted world there is no real
economy in our community which is why
it's so important to get to the other
side of this
the province's public health officer is
clapping down because
cases are high in this part of british
columbia we're starting to see
cases increase again in that community
and particularly in the past week
with the more worrisome cluster of the
p1 brazil
variant of concern we have the variance
in circulation particularly the uk
variant
brazilian variant and these are
significantly more
transmissible probably twice as
contagious the message has always been
get outside it was the safest bet but
it's what happened in the apre
that is taking away the fun skiing is
what kept me sane through the whole
pandemic
just to get outdoors and have some
outdoor fun
it's a three-week pause here and is
taking a big chunk out of the spring ski
season much like it did last year a
spokesperson for the resort says
it was caught by surprise but it will
comply with health orders
donna all right robin gill in whistler
b.c thanks
quebec is also seeing a steady rise in
cases the premier warns tighter
restrictions may be needed
there too the highest case counts are in
five regions outside montreal
premier francois lago says the biggest
concern is social gatherings
police have been ordered to crack down
on rule breakers over the easter weekend
the quebec government is also
considering moving the 9 30 p.m curfew
back to 8 p.m prime minister justin
trudeau revealed today more vaccine
doses are
on the way sooner than expected the
timeline for most canadian adults to be
vaccinated will move up as a result
confidence in the vaccine rollout though
has taken a hit with all the changing
advice about who should avoid the
astrazeneca shot
as michael couture explains public
health officials are trying to drive
home the message that any vaccine you
are eligible
for is still your best shot
prime minister justin trudeau says it's
possible a lot of canadians will have at
least their first dose of vaccine before
summer
even really starts that confidence comes
as he announced pfizer
is moving up delivery of 5 million doses
of the covid19 vaccine
combined across the currently approved
vaccines
canada is now on track to receive at
least
44 million doses of vaccine
by the end of june that doesn't include
the single dose johnson
johnson vaccine canada will start
receiving those shipments
at the end of april but it does include
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine which has
been getting a lukewarm reception on the
street
since the national advisory committee on
immunization
is recommending provinces paused
delivery of that vaccine
to adults under the age of 55 because of
rare reports
of blood clots yes i would be very
afraid to take it
why is that because it's not safe yet
this man's first shot was from pfizer
and if his second dose has to be
astrazeneca
or nothing yeah yeah i would do it yeah
i wouldn't let it deter me from taking
it
but i would definitely if you know if i
had a choice i would opt for another
another option hoping to halt
that hesitancy prime minister trudeau
has been touring vaccination clinics
like this one in ottawa
reinforcing the notion that you should
take the first vaccine you're offered
that message is being echoed by quebec
premier francois lago who was given the
pfizer shot last week
the astrazeneca vaccine is safe for
people
over 55 the greater risk
is to refuse to get vaccinated
canada's top doctor says science is
shifting to keep up with the real world
data
the initial clinical trial where tens of
thousands
will not pick up rare events dr
tam adds as more people get vaccinated
the science continues to evolve and
guidance for vaccines
will have to follow donna michael
couture
thanks we know the heartbreaking toll
the pandemic has taken on residents in
long-term care homes in canada
now there is new context about just how
dismal medical care was in many of those
homes and how canada compares
to other countries of all the deaths
from covet 19
in canada 69 percent were in long-term
care homes
the international average is 41 percent
and as ross lord reports there are mixed
opinions on how much
things have changed in the spirit of
understanding a problem before we can
fix it
the canadian institute for health
information is drilling down on the
devastation in long-term care homes
some of the findings are already widely
known that long-term care and retirement
homes
have been disproportionately affected by
covert 19 in canada
others are revealing like this one
long-term care residents
received less medical care during the
first wave than in normal years
meaning fewer physician visits and they
were less
often transferred to hospital for the
treatment of chronic conditions and
infections residents also had fewer
contacts with friends and family
which was associated with higher rates
of depression the total number of
resident deaths from all causes
was higher than normal during the first
wave even in parts of the country with
fewer covet 19 cases
so when you saw a significant growth in
the rate of what we call excess deaths
in these settings
it really showed that it wasn't just due
to covet itself but it was actually a
collapse in
the provision of care that was occurring
in many of these homes
the report says nearly one in three
long-term care homes
experienced an outbreak during the first
wave we have a grossly underfunded
system
in canada where we rank number one in
the world of having our deaths
at such a high proportion in our
long-term care homes the good news
funding and staffing is increasing
measures that helped quebec greatly
reduce
long-term care deaths in the second wave
the ontario government is recruiting
thousands of front-line workers
a move applauded by nursing homeowners
but a health care union
fears the number of new arrivals won't
keep pace with those
leaving work from burnout illness and
child care
this year alone in ontario we're
training 6 000 psws we're going to lose
10 000 to attrition alone a year after
the pandemic started
making improvements for the future is
still easier said than done
ross lord global news an arson
investigation is underway in british
columbia
after back-to-back fires at three halls
operated by the freemason society
the first fire was reported shortly
before 7 a.m in north vancouver
less than an hour later two more masonic
halls in the region were also
on fire police say a 42 year old man has
now been arrested and arson charges
are being recommended the prime minister
questioned about misconduct
in the military coming up what did he
know about allegations against canada's
former top soldier
prime minister trudeau was pressed today
to clarify who knew what
and when about a sexual misconduct
allegation involving the highest ranks
of the canadian military
there have been conflicting comments
about the 2018 allegation against
general jonathan vance
today when the prime minister was asked
directly whether he personally knew
about it
he gave a clear and simple answer our
ottawa bureau chief mercedes stevenson
explains when global news first broke
the story about sexual misconduct
allegations against general jonathan
vance
the prime minister in his office said
neither mr trudeau
nor his staff were aware of those
allegations
and that they learned about them from
our reporting a few weeks later the
prime minister's office
changed its tune and admitted senior
staff
were aware of allegations being made in
2018
we wanted a clear answer from the prime
minister on whether
his answer had changed too here's how he
responded today my office knew there was
allegations that were brought forward we
did not know the substance of those
allegations
until the global news reporting prime
minister did you know about
any allegations of any concerns of
sexual misconduct
regardless of the content in 2018 or
before and when you extended
general vance's term and gave him a
raise no
so what did you know still there are
questions as to why
senior staff or the defense minister
harjit sajin
didn't think the prime minister should
be made aware that allegations had been
made
especially when extending vance's term
or giving him a pay raise
last week minister sajin's claims about
how he handled the vance allegations
were thrown into question at committee
by expert testimony
the current military ombudsman backed
assertions of his predecessor
that sajin was the proper reporting
authority for concerns about general
vance
the head of the sensitive investigations
unit for the military police
also contradicts sagin's claim that
reporting the allegation
would have been political interference a
claim that sajin
repeated again today donna all right
mercedes stevenson in ottawa thank you
and one more military note a day before
canada's mission in iraq was set to
expire the federal government has
announced it is being extended
500 canadian troops are involved in
operation impact now the extension
allows that to increase up to 850 troops
if needed
until the end of next march canada has
been helping a coalition of countries
fight the so-called islamic state in
iraq and syria
since 2014. ahead heinous attacks on
asian americans prompt
hate crime investigations
police in new york are searching for
suspects who carried out brutal assaults
on asian americans
the latest happened in broad daylight in
midtown manhattan
a 65-year-old woman was kicked and
stomped on
it was caught on a security camera and a
warning the video is
disturbing it happened outside an
apartment building yesterday morning
a man approached the woman kicked her in
the stomach and repeatedly stomped on
her
before walking away she went to the
hospital with serious injuries
a security guard inside the lobby
watched it happen and did nothing
another man closed the door to the
building and left the woman
on the ground the building management
company says they
have been suspended the police hate
crimes unit is now
asking for public help in identifying
the suspect
and another attack on an asian-american
man is also under investigation he was
beaten on this busy subway train in
brooklyn
it's not clear when it took place or
what happened before the assault
we're not going to show you the whole
thing it's too violent the assailant
choked the man until he collapsed and
then
he walked off the train at the next stop
the nypd is asking the public for help
in that case too urging
anyone with information to come forward
in minneapolis the teenager who took the
video of george floyd's arrests and his
final moments
took the stand in the second day of the
murder trial of former police officer
derrick chauvin
she appeared off camera because she was
a minor at the time
in her testimony she described seeing
floyd as she says
terrified scared and begging for his
life eshovan pressed his knee on the 46
year old black man's neck
even though it was her video that
brought the world's attention to floyd's
death she says she
feels remorse for being unable to help
him
i have black i have a black father i
have a black brother i have black
friends
and i i look at that and i look at how
that could have been one of them
it's been nice i stayed up
apologizing
and apologizing
to george floyd for not doing more and
not physically interacting
and not saving his life but it's like
it's not what i should have done it's
what he should have done
is charged with second-degree murder
third degree murder and second-degree
manslaughter in connection with floyd's
death
the trial will continue for several more
weeks
virtual gurus still ahead the remote
recruiters thriving
in alberta
you're watching global national
a bright spot in the uk today it was the
warmest march day in 53 years
temperatures soared to above 24 degrees
in some places
it was convenient timing to enjoy the
outdoors strict lockdown measures eased
yesterday allowing people to gather
outside in groups of six and in japan
the cherry blossoms are bursting into
bloom earlier than any other year on
record
the city of kyoto has tracked the peak
bloom date for over 1200 years and says
spring flowering has been shifting
earlier over the past century
well finding moments of joy hasn't been
easy in the last year especially for
those who have been forced out of work
in alberta employment of women has been
driven down
to a low not seen in two decades it's a
harsh reality
a tech entrepreneur in calgary is
working to address
she has overcome a difficult past and as
heather urex west reports
she's now helping those who don't always
fit into a corporate box
bobby rossette came to calgary for the
opportunities
i moved here to work in oil and gas just
like a lot of people were moving out
here to get
oil and gas jobs at first the work was
steady
rissette was busy all the time but when
the price of oil collapsed in 2015
she and thousands of others were laid
off
at that time there's a lot of people in
calgary trying to find work
and there's just no opportunities for me
as an indigenous member of the lgbtq2
community
reset knew she was facing discrimination
too
it's something she had watched her two
moms struggle against for years
from a young age i've seen prejudices
against us as our family i've seen a lot
of
uh you know it was a lot of heartbreak
for us to deal with
that's essentially what compiled me to
say you know what i i got to be able to
build a platform that i can do this
and that i can provide work to those
that are going through the same thing as
i uh
doing good five years later reset is now
the ceo of a rapidly growing tech
startup
virtual gurus connects companies with
skilled assistants who work remotely
a model that is thriving during these
coveted times
i have like five six clients at the
moment and everyone's different
so every day is different no two days
are the same
stacy wells is one of 400 contractors
who is now working as a virtual
assistant because of assets company
most of the contractors are women many
like wells are indigenous and living in
remote communities
you know sometimes i surprise myself
though because i'll look online and i'll
look in in our community and i'll see
all the people that we're providing work
for and you know
it's kind of it brings a tear to my
sometimes this week the company closed
more than a million dollars in new
investment there are big plans for
growth
but for reset every new hire still feels
deeply personal you think back to your
mom yeah
yeah i always do i always think back to
what my mom went through
and that's what drives her to keep
striving for more
heather urex west global news calgary
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is kinsman park south in regina
there are beautiful spots all over
canada please email yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye